[Musique]
le 2 décembre 1993
nous avions rendez vous à la station
nation avec un entomologiste spécialiste
du grillon du métro parisien
il existe en effet dans ce métro une
forme très particulière et très variée
mais l'espèce la plus singulière la plus
étrange est constituée par une famille
de grillons elle est apparue dès 1910
dans cette nouvelle niche écologique et
ne subissent pas haïr
cette espèce très fragile je supporte
pour s'épanouir que les conditions du
métro parisien
voilà qui donne à réfléchir sur les
capacités d'adaptation de la vie sur et
sous sa tutelle
le 2 décembre 1993 donc nous circulions
vers 17 heures sur la ligne numéro un
qui va de la défense à vincennes
rames bondées
audet chaleur écho grinçant trains qui
s'arrêtent et qui repart sans cesse
fatigue sur tous les visages fatigués a
pâti
tout alors quelque chose d'étrange est
arrivé un homme s'est mis à parler il
vous plaît c'est le conducteur qui vous
parle alors je voudrais vous dire que ce
soir c'est la grande fête des problèmes
il arrange pas tout d'abord donc nous
arrêterons pas à l'ombre parce que
il paraît que la joconde manifestent
dans la rue ensuite le palais royal
on s'arrête pas de problème mais salon
pour angie correspondance vous ne
pourrez pas sortir 28 dans la rue et la
rejoignent alors ce que je vous
demanderai à louvres c'est de ne pas
nourrir les français parce que sinon ça
poserait d'énormes problèmes à moi
d'abord à vous ensuite et en fait tout
est de toute façon le train ne
s'arrêtera pas alors je compte sur vous
pour être sérieux
n'ouvrez pas les freins de secours à
londres deux trains de toutes façons de
s'arrêter j'y peux rien et de mener
pendant des années c'est pas de ma faute
j'en étais sûr ne vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien simplement jardin tout
petit problème avec le 32 ans j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aient un voyageur
qui a encore fait des siennes
je réfléchis ouais ça doit être ça toute
façon je vous tiens au courant à quoi
qu'il arrive peu au courant quand il ya
un mois que j'en sais quelque chose
écoutez ça risque de s'éterniser enfin
pas longtemps disons peut-être une
petite minute tous deux finalement cette
recette ça fait des années complètement
que je vais voulez communiquer alors ce
sera une noix de veau fin noa noa avec
un x 1 noix de veau aux pruneaux et aux
raisins leur en principe pour les pour
les auvergnats je conseille de supprimer
poireaux et de mettre oseille
il préfère alors vous avez un petit
carnet vous notez alors les ingrédients
lors ces seuils pour quatre personnes
alors quatre personnes c'est à dire si
vous êtes 8 vous multipliez par deux et
si vous n'êtes que deux balles vous en
remettrez la moitié au congélateur parce
que ça va vous poser un problème pour
couper alors voilà de la noix de veau
vous en avez pour 800 grammes à 800
grammes de poireaux ou d'oseille il ya
en principe ça se compte en billets
l'oseille
rabat
un décilitre dos les deux cuillères à
soupe d'huile d'arachide une gousse
d'ail
ah ça y est on me fait signe que je peux
avancer je suis désolé un jeu je vous
donnerai la recette un peu plus tard
alors allez pouvoir ou la v m à c coupé
en rondelles
vous allez on fait cuire à l'étuvée 100
minutes est pourquoi je n'ai pas fait
cette recette parce qu'elle me paraît un
peu compliquée moi je me limite toujours
en général les spaghettis à l'eau comme
ça quand ces conflits
je rajoute un peu peur et ça me suffit
parce que sinon et à leur suite des
réjouissances palais royal alors palais
royal on s'arrête mais attention il n'y
aura pas de sortie dans la rue pas
question d'aller dans la rue
j'utiliserai seulement les
correspondances voilà
et puis qu'on ne vous avait pas toucher
aux freins de secours je vais vous
donner la halle à la fin de l'article
je suis pas si vous avez le temps de
préparer les casseroles et ou qu'un
chauffe et de fourneaux mais on va pas
tarder à commencer
alors attention pas de sortie dans la
rue rien des correspondances je ne sais
pas si vous avez remarqué mais j'ai
alors commis un train et que fait un
principe pas le droit de leur don est
une idée je suis obligé d'attendre
je vais me les mettre au régime
alors pour en revenir à marseille
vous ajoutez les raisins vous saler
poivrer si nécessaire
j'inspire com
je me contente d'inspirer c'est déjà pas
si mal
bon pour ceux qui t'ont c'est qu'ils
désespèrent en arrive à 2000
on nous répète frein de secours ça me
poserait des problèmes et à vous aussi
bah oui je suis bien obligé de tout
raconter
alors voilà on est
l'ag
bah écoute et sortez vos crayons
le pass 1 pâte ben oui je suis bien
obligée à la bombe à écouter en
attendant puisqu'on va pique-niqué
allons-y sortant tente en les carnets
bon
or c'est gentil merci ça vous a plu
janouille prochain compromis je vais
d'ailleurs qui porte maillot
je vous donne la recette en vidéo voilà
vous avez de la chance d'avoir fini
parce qu n'est pas encore arrivé au bout
avec le bordel qu'ils assurent
et vous m'invitez depuis 2
d'ailleurs là que pour la cuisine
là-bas au moins la chance
oui
tel que c'est parti tel que c'est parti
vous avez la recette inventée il ya plus
que lui
on est bien obligé ont sonné
je pensais que je ferai
nous ne sommes pas des robots et
oui aller m'asseoir
et les petits pois en rose
non
voilà plus tard nous avons filmé le
grillon du métro nous vous le présentons
dans un prochain numéro mais en
attendant nous avons pensé que ce crayon
la vallée bien l'autre et qu'ils
n'avaient été pour le remercie
[Musique]